we've just had confirmation of the names  of  two of the victims of this tragic train  crash yesterday  uh first of all the conductor  donald dinney was aboard that train  and is one of the three people to have  lost their lives  uh we know it was a scot rail passenger  train on which 12 people in total were  on board six staff and six passengers  but that's donald denny the conductor  who was on the train  who was killed with the derailment we  also know that the driver of the train  uh was one of those who died and his  name was brett  mcculloch so we've got confirmation  two of the three victims of that train  derailment yesterday the driver brett  mcculloch  and the conductor donald denney